recently I was in New Zealand asking the
real tough questions like where did the
earth come from like what was it before
it was there like how did it get here
those who were game to answer my
question
realized that an explosion was important
Earth's formation
I suppose it was created from space I
don't know I don't know things explode
in space I suppose just heaps a gas
built up bang got a planet same with the
Sun and everything else sue saying it
came out of some say once that would
have been gas here would have been
explosion and then after that there was
just a fine of error mmm that's a really
good fish net so I suppose that we whole
bunch of gases and then being planet
started revolving all the gases are
right was there a particular explosion
you had in mind
perhaps one you learned about from a
popular American sitcom from the Big
Bang maybe yeah yeah the big thing Big
Bang Theory or something like that it
was a bunch of dust those from doing a
Big Bang I've been to a couple of
museums here in New Zealand and then it
all starts with a big bang it says and
then you see a lot of volcanic action
The Big Bang Theory that's one of the
theories of how earth is created so the
Big Bang created the earth yes
like boom North was there now the
trouble with explosions which I was
trying to hint at is that they tend to
blow stuff apart they're more
destructive than constructive but what
we're looking for is a mechanism to form
the earth to bring things together so
how could the earth form out of an
explosion masses that were then
clustered together and compacted
together and consolidated it was debris
that gathered together through gravity
okay where did that debris come from the
the Big Bang I suppose but you know that
big explosion led to a whole bunch of
debris yes and then it collapsed damn
that glaze of gravity yes now we're on
the right track the gravitational
attraction between all mass is what
causes matter to clump together into
galaxies stars and planets there's only
one little problem
after the Big Bang there were only two
elements hydrogen and helium in the
whole
universe so how could we form the earth
including its oxygen carbon nitrogen
silicon aluminium I say it that way for
my Australian viewers how could we form
all these other elements well the truth
is the Big Bang didn't form the earth at
least not directly the Big Bang formed
galaxies of stars let's focus in on one
of these stars in particular one whose
contents will go on to form the earth in
this star the lighter elements are
fusing together to form heavier elements
carbon nitrogen oxygen and eventually
all the elements up to iron now when
this star runs out of nuclei to fuse it
explodes and out of that debris could
form either directly our solar system or
another star which then explodes and
forms our solar system so you could say
the Sun is a second or third generation
star and you might say well that would
have taken a very long time to occur and
it's true the earth has been around for
about four-and-a-half billion years but
the Big Bang happened 13.7 billion years
ago so if my arm span represents the
time that the earth has been here then
the Big Bang would be about here you're
doing a bang-up job guys so when people
tell you that we're all made of Stardust
they're not trying to be metaphorical or
poetic necessarily they're being literal
the iron in your blood was actually
formed in the core of a star and
millions of degrees
we and the world around us can only
exist because of the elements that were
formed in earlier stars